change comes from individual action
forming a mass movement a collective
action it can be disheartening of course
to see that
there are these you know corporations
monopolizing the markets and there is
this proliferation of misinformation
that is demoralizing it can feel like
we're up against this almost
inassailable beast of a problem but
ultimately there are shifts happening
and there are cracks forming in the
otherwise sturdy armor of these
industries and we are starting to get
the message heard by people who maybe
wouldn't have heard it otherwise i think
it's just really important to recognize
that we have the power to influence
change for the choices that we make and
veganism is a stepping stone i think to
recognizing the broader impact that we
all have collectively but also
individually and it's by no means the
only step we need to take but it's a
huge step in the right direction in
fixing tackling addressing acknowledging
so many different issues that up until
this point we have often turned a blind
eye too sadly